I finally know what I have to do
I toss you up they just don't wanna give
up I can't do this all day
this is nothing we were ever trained for
I'm bringing the party to you
[Music]
I guess we're stuck together partners
[Applause]
to become the hero
[Music]
so what you don't know
[Applause]
what happens now determines what happens
to the rest of the party
[Music]
it's my last day in LA so I thought I
would just go live and see what you guys
are doing so I have something a little
exciting to share with you today I think
I don't really know what it is
I got a parcel from none other than mr.
Mark Ruffalo himself and I thought I
would open it online for you guys I
don't know what it is I'm quite excited
see what it is whoa yo that's dope so I
guess this is the New Avengers Avengers
infinity war may 4th hi Tom I'm so
excited to be working with you on
infinity war I thought you'd like to be
the first to see the poster for the
movie enjoy Mark Ruffalo the crack team
of spider-man and Hulk leaking you all
the best information from behind the
scenes here's the poster they should
just let them do all their press
releases accidentally leaking stuff from
now on but it's finally confirmed it's
time to start freaking out put the team
on high alert they're dropping the
infinity war trailer tomorrow the funny
thing about that is that you may have
seen the Russos post the - like I
reposted it so it's like okay it's gonna
come on Thursday but then they drop this
sort of like fan mash-up of Marvel phase
1 phase 2 phase 3 of like all the stuff
that's happened so far just to get
people ready like oh this is the
culmination of everything that
everybody's been freaking out about for
so long and say we're dropping it
tomorrow so I wonder if the Russos were
confused about when they were dropping
it or if there's people that manage the
social media that we're just miss
communicating with people but whatever
totally doesn't matter I'll be doing
that
IMAX take a giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video oh that's a new
winner at the end of this - there'll be
a bunch of marble stuff this week
because it'll probably take a couple
days to get through all the infinity war
stuff but the whole thing about this I
love the way they work the fans into the
trailer tease like they really do like
people reacting to their trailers some
studio
get really upset by that they'll take
videos down but I think it's just a
case-by-case basis like sometimes they
like it and I think it just depends on
what the fans are doing with the
material that belongs to the studios
because technically all that footage
like any of the images belong to them
it's their IP so it winds up being this
funny gray area that I always try to
tiptoe around but they're just like full
in on infinity war with the fans because
the funny thing is is that if you've
ever met people from marble most of them
don't know what's going on with infinity
war either like a lot of them have
nothing to do with the movie like you
have the people that work in the comics
sometimes they get to see stuff early
but most of the time they don't I did a
breakdown of the leak footage earlier
this week like I said I think the actual
trailer they released whatever the first
trailer is even if it's just a teaser
trailer will be a shinier version of
that so there'll be some of the same
footage that people saw at d23 in a
comic-con but for the most part they'll
just be jumping around to all the big
characters like who get shots of
spider-man Iron Man in their new suits
you'll see what Thanos who looks like
finally you'll see a version of him with
the Infinity Gauntlet but the whole
thing of this movie is that it's
supposed to be Thanos quest so he
doesn't have all the gems by the end of
the movie everybody is still wondering
about the soul gem there's still a
number of places that it could pop up
and a lot of people are wondering about
black panther because if they're
featured in the trailer in T'Challa and
Winter Soldier and an army of Wakanda
soldiers are getting ready to fight off
some of the Black Order it means they're
coming for either vibranium or one of
the infinity gems implying that there is
an infinity gem in Wakanda but the thing
is is that we might actually not see
that till the infinity war movie like we
could go through the entire Black
Panther movie with him fighting the
golden Jaguar for the throne of Wakanda
without them ever referencing anything
that's going to happen in infinity war I
point you to the example of Thor in the
way they marketed Thor Ragnarok
think about what happens to that
character at the end of the movie in the
way all the trailers look you wouldn't
have known about that big twist just
from seeing all the trailers so because
the soul gem popping up somewhere is
still kind of a secret it feels weird
for them to spoil that with the infinity
war trailer so I would be very surprised
if we see that anywhere before next
February when we get that black panther
movie and like I said
could just have the soul gem in infinity
war and then the person who has the soul
gem goes to Wakanda and that's why the
Black Order goes there but I know you
guys all have a thousand questions so
just post them in the comments below and
I'll try to address them when I do my
infinity war trailer video I'm gonna try
and keep the video from being too long
we could talk about infinity war all day
so there's just some stuff that I'll
just save for bonus videos but there is
one idea that I do want to tease because
they've been talking about doing an a
force movie during phase for some time
so the other day they posted this
picture they were doing the big photo
shoot so all the female characters from
Marvel got together and took a picture
but even if it's going to be a while
they've actually started talking about
doing an all-female team up movie which
is basically the a force from the comics
if you're not a big comic book reader or
you don't know what that is it's just an
all-female version of the Avengers
led by she-hulk now obviously there are
a couple of characters in comic book a
force that they don't have in the movies
yet like there's America Chavez
there's Spider Woman there's she hold so
because it's gonna be a while before we
see a movie like that they could
introduce some of the other supporting
characters and then just do that
sometime during phase four but like
Black Widow
Tessa Thompson's Valkyrie they've all
said that they've had conversations with
Kevin Feige
about doing a female team up movie in a
force is just the best opportunity to do
that but I know there are some of you
that are also really hoping that at some
point they get crazy enough to try an
ultimate movie that would be like crazy
cosmic Galactus level stuff and it just
depends on which characters they're able
to do because I don't think you could do
altima --tz-- without doing Galactus and
they can't do that without a sharing
arrangement with Fox so there's just a
whole bunch of stuff happening this week
obviously there's all the DC TV crisis
stuff that's happening my new video for
that will post tonight and I'll just
post updates on infinity war and all
that stuff as it drops the trailer will
actually probably drop pretty early so
just make sure you wake up really early
or you just be prepared to get that
alert when I post the video super early
but now's the time to get crazy make
sure you keep an extra pair of pants on
hand in case your body just completely
shuts down the minute you see it and if
you weren't already excited enough we
get infinity war in Maine
next year the year after that we get
Avengers 4 you don't have to wait two
years to get that fourth Avengers film
it's almost back-to-back and then right
after Avengers 4 we get spider-man
homecoming 2 and that's the beginning of
phase 4 like they're basically going to
destroy the Marvel Universe and whenever
we see afterwards the New Avengers is
gonna be nuts congratulations to the
giveaway winner from my last video
Alexander please private message me so I
can get your contact details to answer
your question I'll call an audible and
say Logan is my favorite Marvel movie
even though technically that's a Fox
Marvel movie but like I said there'll be
a new round of the giveaway when I post
that trailer video tomorrow click here
for my breakdown of the league trailer
footage and click here for my Easter
eggs from the first part of the crisis
crossover thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome see you guys
tonight